on va partir dans le Var avec vous
Camille vigong Le Coat c'est là que vous
avez enquêté pendant près de 2 ans à
fréjust précisément la ville conquise
par David rachlim en 2014 les rapasses
aux éditions Les Arènes fait à appppui
vous décrivez au fond l'afférisme la
corruption le clienténisme du maire eren
et de son entourage regardez c'est dans
l'invitation de Marco Pomier on en parle
toutes les deux juste
après si on vous invite Camille Vigon le
CAT c'est parce que vous avait brisé
l'omerta sur l'une des vitrines du parti
de Marine Le Pen la ville de Fréjus
dirigée depuis 2014 par David Rachlin
vice-président du rassemblement national
ave de tempête sur la cité varroise
c'est un système politicofancier un
système quasi mafieux mis en place par
David Rachin où affairisme clanisme
prospère au détriment des citoyens de
vous Camille vigogne lecoat nous
retenons la journaliste grand reporter à
l'OPS après plusieurs années à L'Express
passé par Fran 5 TF1 et bien sûr par LCP
aujourd'hui vous dissquez l'exercice du
pouvoir du RN de années d'enquête au
cœur du système Racheline vous dites que
la corruption et le clientélisme règne à
Fréjus à l'image de cet entrepreneur
local toutpuissant qui rafle les marchés
publics de la ville vous vous êtes
plongé dans les registre de la mairie à
la mairie de Frégus l'entrepreneur du
BTP est comme chez lui entre sans
rendez-vous dans le bureau du maire
plusieurs fois par mois sans oublier les
déboirs de l'élu varois sont train de
vie démesuré au-delà de ses revenus
bijou montre de luxe l'argent liquide
coule à flot l'arbre de Noël l'appelle
certain et vous affirmez il met souvent
le cap sur saintropé où il lui arrive de
lâcher un SMIC dans une plage privée car
et VIP champagne mésimé espace réservé
l'addition se règle exclusivement
liquide des dérives des dérapages
racistes et antisémites aussi de la part
du maire comme de son entourage jusqu'au
salut nazi personnellement je n'ai
jamais entendu quelqu'un d'aussi
antisémite c'est hallucinant ça confine
à la pathologie témoignage date
correspondance contrat un récit
chirurgical sous le feu des critiques
des ténors du rassemblement national a
commencé par la patronne ce livre est un
livre d'une militante politique bon le
titre d'ailleurs le le démontre euh si
la justice considère qu'elle doit se
saisir de ses ragots ou de ses
accusations elle le fera alors Camille
vigogne le CAT après ce livre explosif
le rassemblement national ne va-t-il pas
finir par lâcher David
Rachlin c'est possible ça ce scénario là
moi je pense que l'avenir le dira que si
les choses deviennent trop compliquées
pour David Rachlin on il n'est pas
assuré d'un soutien sans faille du
Rassemblement National Marine Le Pen a
assuré qu'il avait encore toute sa
confiance jusqu'à qui a preuve du
contraire et toute la il est toujours
soutenu par le clan par Jordan Bardella
par janlin la Capelle bien sûr c'est un
des fidèles des plus fidèles de de
Marine Le Pen et Jordan Bardella Marine
Le Pen était encore au mois de juin sur
un voilier dans le Golf de saint-tropé
dans un des établissements de
l'entrepreneur en question avec David
rachelin donc évidemment il fait
toujours partie des intimes mais en
public on observe ces derniers mois que
David rashin est absent de toutes les
grandes manifestations du rassemblement
national avec mar le ne s'affiche pas en
photo avec lui euh c'est suffisamment
rare et incongru au regard de ces
dernières années pour imaginer qu'en
tout cas il y a une sorte de prévention
des potentielles suites que pourrait
avoir cette affaire d'autant qu'il y a
des échéances électorales importantes
qui arrivent quand il arrive à la tête
de la ville en 2014 au terme il faut le
rappeler hein d'une triangulaire
fratricie avec deux candidats de droite
s'il y avait pas eu trois candidats il
n'aurait jamais été élu il promet de la
désendetter cette ville 170 millions de
dettes au départ et Marine Le Pen qui
cite régulièrement en exemple Fréjus
pour sa bonne gestion en réalité c'est
c'est tout le contraire c'est en tout
cas sur les deux promesses de campagne
phare de David Rachlin le désentêtement
de la ville et la fin d'un système de
corruption d'affairisme qui était à
l'œuvre il ça il faut vraiment le
préciser avant lui déjà dans le
département et dans
l'agglomération bien sûr et le précédent
maire est tombé pour ses raisons et
cetera et et sur ces deux promesses de
campagne on peut dire que David rachelin
ne les tient pas sur l'endettement il y
a fait des efforts au début qui ont été
salués notamment dans le premier mandat
par la Cour régionale des comptes mais
uniquement permis par la vente
d'énormément de terrains municipaux ce
qui fait mécaniquement rentrer des de
l'argent dans dans les caisses de la
mairie mais ça a pas suivi sur le
deuxème mandat tout en continuant à
vendre des terrains il s'est réendetté
réendetté réendetté ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui la ville est dans une
légèrement plus mauvaise situation
financière qu'en 2014 et sur la
dimension affairiste et corruption alors
là l'amplifié avec de forts soupçons de
marché public viciés au profit du
parrain local du BTP il s'appelle
Alexandre Barbero que Racheline va
rencontrer dès le début dès début 2015
qui est-il précisément Alexandre Barbero
et pourquoi aucun contrat ne lui échappe
dans la région alors il est surnommé
Pac-Man comme la petite bête des jeux
vidéos qui mange tout par ses
concurrents qui ont très peur de lui ou
don Corleon c'est un homme extrêmement
puissant sans plus puissance disent
absolument tous les acteurs locaux que
les maires de Fréjus ou de
saint-raaphaël c'est l'acteur dominant
dans le BTP est-ce que vous citez un
homme d'affair installé dans la région
qui vous dit si je parle je prends un
risque pour ma vie bien sûr bien sûr il
y a il y a une vraie omerta on sait tout
le monde sait dans le dans dans dans ce
le sud-est enfin l'est Var que comment
Alexandre barbéot tient une partie de sa
puissance de ses liens avec les
politiques et moi ce que j'ai pu
documenter parce que c'est un important
de documenter ces faits c'est que il
entretient une relation extrêmement
nourrie avec David Rachin mais mais
comme comme on en voit jamais avec un
entrepreneur c'est-à-dire que plusieurs
fois par mois il y a des déjeunés à son
domicile qui sont organisés il entre on
l'a vu dans le reportage sans frapper à
la mairie David Rachin va sur le bateau
de d'Alexandre Barbero il va dans le
l'appartement à Monaco de son ex
beaufrère regardez le prix du formul 1
et tout de suite des enveloppes d'argent
liquide circulent et c'est là que
en plus de toutes sortes de cadeaux bien
sûr des témoins des témoins m mont
raconté avoir observé des enveloppes en
craft chez David Rachin et certains de
ses proches ces enveloppes en tout cas
cet argent liquide qui est beaucoup dans
les poches du maire on le retrouve dans
des achats précis que là encore j'ai pu
retracer alors on va y venir aux achats
mais pour bien comprendre en gros c'est
barbéos d'après tous les témoignages que
vous avez pu recueillir qui donnerait
ses enveloppes en liquide ou ses proches
à Racheline en échange des marchés
publics il existe un fort soupçon de
effectivement d'achat ou en tout cas de
de cadeaux visant qui a expliquer en
partie la l'hégémonie de cet
entrepreneur sur les contrats publics
mais aussi en partie sur les contrats
privés parce qu'il faut savoir que cette
entreprise là est présente sur la
plupart des gros contrats privés
pourquoi parce que selon les acteurs du
secteur il ne serait possible d'obtenir
un permis de construire du maire que si
on montre que pour la le raccordement on
passera par l'entrepreneur que pour l'
pour les plans passera par l'architecte
et cetera donc c'est pas seulement
quelque chose qui concerne les marchés
publics c'est aussi quelque chose qui
concerne tout le domaine privé c'est
bien de le le le préciser vous l'avez
dit il flambe Racheline il aime il aime
la fête son surnom c'est la cagole il
adore saint tropé le sujet de Marco
Pomier disait il peut lâcher un SMIC en
un weekend sur une plage euh tout ça
c'est c'est l'argent de de
Barbro en tout cas c'est de l'argent
liquide la c'est pas l'argent de ses
émoluments il gagne environ 8000 € par
mois si on additionne ces différents
salaires publics ils sont tous connus
c'est beaucoup c'est un bon salaire mais
ça suffit pas à expliquer ce mode de vie
quelque part si David Rachin était juste
un flambeur ça le regarde c'est sa vie
privée évidemment on a le droit d'aimer
les mondes de luxe on a le droit d'aimer
faire la fête bon voilà le problème
c'est effectivement la traçabilité de
cet argent d'où vient
moi j'ai aussi obtenu des
enregistrements dans lequel on entend
David Rachin s'inquiéter on l'entend
évoquer l'argent liquide on l'entend
évoquer des stratagèmes pour ne pas se
faire prendre en cas de perquisition
tout ça ce sont des indices qui gent un
fort soupçon sur effectivement la source
de ce train de vie après il m'appartient
pas de qualifier
effectivement nature jurdique et à lire
l'enquête documenter les différents
témoignages que vous rapportez ça n'est
jamais Rachel qui paye c'est bien pour
ça que c'est c'est pas traçable ce
toutes ces dépenses ces achats se font
par un intermédiaire il y a toujours une
forme de prê nom soit c'est son
chauffeur pour la montre à 15000 € soit
c'est son ami pour un bracelet à 6000 h
c'est ça la façon de faire oui la le
premier élément matériel que j'ai réussi
à à récolter c'est cette montre dont on
a beaucoup parlé une montre à 15000 €
comment on peut expliquer aujourd'hui
quand on est un élu de la République
qu'on demande à son chauffeur par
ailleurs assistant parlementaire
en partie au au Sénat de d'aller lui
acheter une montre en liquide au nom du
chauffeur et par ailleurs moi
j'interroge David Rachlin parce qu'on a
eu un long entretien dans son bureau il
y a quelques mois et il niit à quatre ou
cinq reprises n'avoir jamais posséder
cette montre et en fait alors qu'il y a
des photos qui TM heureusement quelques
quelques mois avant j'aV j'avais demandé
un photographe de de de prendre son
poignet en photo et j'avais cette mot et
et et il ne changera de version que des
mois plus tard en expliquant avoir reçu
un héritage récupéré de 20 20 ans plus
tôt et d'avoir retrouvé en gros de
l'argent liquide dans son dans le
grenier de sa mère et ça s mais dans ce
cas là pourquoi ne pas l'avoir acheté
lui enfin il y a des choses qui sont
absolument incompréhensibles et et qui
jettent effectivement un fort soupçon
sur l'origine de cet argent cette
manière de faire on voit le signal aux
employés municipaux que que tout est
permis d'une certaine manière vous
montrez aussi que dans l'attribution des
logements sociaux on réserve les
meilleurs aux Français et les plus
endommagés voir tuste au bounoule comme
les appellent l'adjointte au logement
oui ce qu'on ce que j'ai pu documenter
c'est un une atmosphère où les propos
racistes n'étaai étai au minimum non
sanctionnés voire parfois encouragé sous
couvert d'humour dans le cadre des
logements sociaux c'est une sorte de
préférence nationale qui dirait pas son
nom on note aussi que l'adjointe au
logement a réservé un très beau logement
pour sa propre fille à loger également
des militant du rassemblement national
qui arrivait parfois d'autres régions
très lointaines tout ça ça raconte en
fait un système où de l'association
sportive à la police municipale en
passant par les logements comme le maire
prend beaucoup de largesse avec ce qu'il
peut faire ou ce qu'il est censé faire
on s'autorise des choses similaires dans
les services municipaux c'est le
ruissellement mais façon façon tout est
permis h il ne dit rien non plus quand
son ancien directeur général des
services Philippe lotio qui est député
HCI à l'Assemblée nationale va faire un
un faux certificat vaccinal pour le
covid il y a énormément de scèesose dire
des des anecdotes est-ce que vous avez
subi des des pressions Camille Vigon
leat est-ce que vous avez même été
intimidé au cours de cette enquête j'ai
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas eu de raison de
de craindre de façon lourde en revanche
que j'ai pu observer c'est un une mise à
l'abri total du parti en l'occurrence
même ici à l'Assemblée nationale le
secrétaire général du groupe qui a
intimé l'ordre aux 88 députés du
rassemblement national de ne plus me
parler sous prétexte que j'étais
militante pour la première fois de ma
vie les députés m'ont donné rendez-vous
loin de l'Assemblée à dans d'autres
arrondissements pour ne pas être vu
c'était c'est mais il me parle encore
heus heureusement toujours on a toujours
des personnes qui vous parl déposé vous
l'avez reçu je n'ai toujours pas reçu de
plainte il a beaucoup communiqué sur ce
dépôt pour l'instant ni moi ni l'éditeur
n'avons reçu quoi que ce soit et si ce
livre débouché sur une enquête
judiciaire avec des perquisitions sur la
base de ce que des élément que que vous
avancez est-ce que ce
serait forme de de bonnes chos nous le
verrons le le temps judiciaire est un
temps plus long que le temps
journalistique moi en l'occurrence j'ai
consacré ces derniers mois à documenter
des faits à faire mon travail de
journaliste et je laisse évidemment à la
justice faire le merci beaucoup Camille
vigong le coat les rapasenquête sur la
mafia varoise de Marine Le Pen c'est à
lire aux éditions Les Arènes